So, what is the final advice you can
give an entrepreneur that starts
a design sprint?
>> The first key benefit of
a sprint is the opportunity for
everyone to participate
in the design and
decision making process
regardless of their background.
A designer or researcher,
someone who is a user experience expert
will be able to come in as a leader, and
they'll be able to create great
prototypes or lead the user testing.
An engineer, or a product manager, or
someone who doesn't have a lot of design
experience, will still
be able to participate.
Because they'll have tremendous
ideas as experts, and
they'll be able to contribute
by learning what the users want.
By allowing the whole team to be
involved in the design process, and
to make meaningful and fast decisions,
this sprint aligns the team, and
now they're a real community
that has a common goal.
The second benefit of a sprint is the
ability to redefine your talent pool.
Often, large companies and
startups are lacking key resources
that they need for the sprint.
Because sprints are short,
they're an opportunity to invite someone
who's missing talent from your team.
If you don't have a researcher, you can
find and hire someone who's an esteemed
colleague or an expert in research, and
they can join you for two to five days.
That makes it so
your talent pool is much larger.
And third, the sprints have
the obvious advantage of speed, and
speed is the ultimate advantage.